let's have a look at this guy over here
now it's not exactly but it's very
similar to a question that a lot of you
have been accounting over the last few
minutes okay we're integrating and then
you've got this sort of garbled mess in
here
how do we deal with it okay now the
first in the first instance while you're
still getting used to these part of the
reason we give your reference sheet is
to use it kind of like as a mental
framework to interpret the questions
that you get presented with so this is
the particular part of the reference
sheet you can find it it is its
character for character it's like the
second or third line on that column this
is the one that will help us okay now in
the end we want you to do so many of
these questions that you can sort of see
this it's like a pair of glasses you
always have in your mind that you can
switch on and say oh I recognize what is
right the reference sheets there to help
you but actually a time penalty if
you've got to look it up every single
time for every question okay it's there
to help you if you've got no memory of
things but if you can remember it
which by doing these questions you will
then that's obviously superior because
you can see it right away if I can see
that I want to get this in the form F -
sign of f of X okay I'm actually pretty
close to that right here's my sign and
then this guy here is my f of X do you
see that so I'm gonna label that
accordingly that's my f of X now if
that's f of X and if it helps you even
write it here on the side what should be
if that's f of X it's a it's a half
right train is exactly right
I want a half to appear here only
problem is there's a three there instead
what a jerk so that's okay we can fix
this easily okay I'm gonna say that
three you're not helping me you're not
anything like what I want you to be so
I'm just going to put you to one side in
fact I'm just gonna take it out of the
integral
altogether okay and then comes my
integral you'll notice I'm leaving a gap
you'll see why in a second
I want that to be 1/2 1/2 sine X on -
that would be nice because it would
exactly match this form with respect to
X now of course you can't just go around
putting halves in because it's more
convenient to you we have to make sure
this stays it quit
to what we had before so what would undo
this multiplication by a half there
should be a two to compensate for that
does that make sense
okay now you don't have to do it exactly
like this but for me it helps me use a
scaffold I know that I have okay now I'm
ready to go this three times two at the
front what's it equal to it's a six and
I'm just going to leave it there because
it kind of has nothing to do with the
integration it's outside of the integral
altogether and then this game here it's
in the perfect form so what does it end
up on in this case - cos what's what's f
of X it's it's x on - I labeled it as
sir right so there's my X on two and
then there's my concert so at this point
I've done the integration which is the
hard part but I should tidy it up that's
six and that negative etc I'll write
that minus out the front and then I'm
home and hosed are you happy with that
okay now you could of course and I hope
you do if you're not sure convince
yourself by differentiating back to here
and you're good to go now the reason why
this is such a useful mental framework
is you could just use it over and over
again this is not a question in your
current exercise it's one from last week
but we can actually use the same kind of
idea right this guy down here right is
the f of X in this case it doesn't match
like this like there's no science they
trigger anything like that what it
matches or what it's going to match is
this guy okay does anyone remember from
last week what does this integrate into
this is our this is a log right not just
any log it's the natural log and then
there's an absolute value which will you
might talk about in more detail later or
maybe not this is what we're going to
end up with okay now have a look if this
is my f of X what should be my f -
it's negative one right very close right
so you like well that's that guys no
help at all right it's not a negative
one so this time I'm going to do a
little quicker to show you what it looks
like when you're more comfortable with
it right that for does it help me no so
I put it outside okay what I want up the
top is a negative one well you can't
just put a negative one there so there's
my negative to compensate do you see you
can start to do this quite quickly once
you get comfortable with it on the
bottom is still that 3 minus X there's
the DX that I had before telling me what
to integrate to and now I'm pretty much
good to go what is that negative for do
nothing much it just hangs out the front
okay yeah just times it by that and then
now I'm in to this form right I'm gonna
do log of what yeah 3 minus X is the f
of X in this case plus my constant and
you're finished max how did I get this
minus 4 out the front ok let's think
right where did the one step at a time
where did the 4 come from it was just in
the original question so is that okay
the 4 came from what was given to me
where do the - come from I introduced
that where'd it come from
you wanna have a go Mary yeah it came
from this numerator I adjusted it so
that it fit this form right does that
make sense you're like I want F - up
there if this is f that's my f - it's
that ok